scikit-learn has long been a popular
library for getting started with machine
learning but if you haven't had a chance
to try it out yet
that's alright let's go check it out
together welcome to cloud AI adventures
where we explore the art science and
tools of machine learning my name is Yu
Feng Guo and on this episode I'll help
you get started using scikit-learn in a
kegel kernel and point you to some
resources to guide your learning moving
forward let's start with a little dash
of history for context scikit-learn was
originally called psyche it's dot learn
and started life as a google Summer of
Code project by david korn apoo the
psychic part of the name came from it
being a sci-fi tool kit and from there
scikit-learn has steadily gained
adoption and popularity to where it is
today a well documented and well-loved
Python machine learning library if you
take a look at scikit-learn at
scikit-learn org and you definitely
should you'll quickly notice that the
version number is quite low 0.19 as of
this recording don't be scared off by
that the library has been around for
quite a while and is very well
maintained and quite reliable what's
really neat about scikit-learn is the
rich suite of tools for doing things
that I like to call a round machine
learning it includes everything from
dataset loading and manipulation to
pre-processing pipelines and metrics in
my opinion the really incredible part
about scikit-learn is the vast
collection of machine learning
algorithms that are all included and you
can just try them out most of them with
minimal code adjustments it's truly an
amazing way to get a handle on what
different types of models do as well as
gain some intuition around how the
various parameters for a given model
perform let's take a look now at a
simple example of scikit-learn
in action on a kegel kernel
we have a data set here of zoo animals
just 101 different animals the
classification task is to determine
which of the seven different classes
these animals are in we'll load it up
using our typical approach with pandas
note that the class type field is in the
final column and that's the column we'll
be interested in predicting on in the
past we shuffled and split the data by
hand using pandas as we can see here now
we won't run that because scikit-learn
has consolidated all these tasks into
one function since they're just so
commonly used and it's called
train tests split it takes care of
creating training and test data for your
features and labels we can see the
shapes of these are exactly as we would
expect the default is to use 25% of the
data for the test and the remaining 75%
for training will use a support vector
classifier or SVC in this example but
you can easily swap out this line for a
different machine learning algorithm
next we'll call fit on it which is
really the same as train and then we'll
call that score to evaluate the model
performance finally we call predict to
try out a few examples as you can see
scikit-learn has an API that maps really
really similarly to the conceptual
workflow making it easy to use so that
was just a very simple quick look and
how you can integrate scikit-learn into
some of the existing work that we've
been doing but I know that you can do
much more dig into the tutorials and the
documentation and make some awesome
models next time we'll talk about the
other side of machine learning with
scikit-learn making predictions and how
to scale that up thanks for watching
this episode of cloudy AI adventures and
if you enjoyed it please like it and
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out and don't
forget to explore the vast world of
machine learning models that
scikit-learn has to offer
all with simple clean API